hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we are in round
2 of our coverage of the 2020 candidates
tournament whenever this tournament is
going to face Magnus Carlsen later in
this year for the World Championship our
competitors today why it's gonna be
played by Fabiano Caruana the only
American in the field he's the highest
rated player that we have here second in
the world only to Magnus Carlsen he won
the kin it's two years ago and then did
lose to Magnus Carlsen later in at that
year for the World Championship in round
one he tied against mvl he's gonna be
looking to get on the board with the
decisive victory with the white pieces
his opponent today playing the black
pieces and that is Khalil Alexian KO
this is the youngest player as well as
the lowest rated player in the
tournament so definitely an opportunity
for Fabiana to get on the board but for
blacks perspective definitely an
opportunity for the youngster to go off
against the highest rated player in the
tournament and see what he can do
Fabiana starts out with d4 and then
after Knight to f6 c4 e6 at Knight to c3
we get into the nimzo-indian always
opening that we don't see too much from
whites anymore a lot of times after the
bishop takes here on c3 we see the pawn
capture here double pawns here just not
something we sell too often from whites
because black just has a lot of good
lines that they can go down about poppy
islands definitely in preparation saying
yeah this is the the opening I want to
go down against this opponent and then
plays f3 and this is the most common way
that you'll see White's responding to
the nimzo-indian defense preparing for
efore preparing to dominate the center
of the board with the pawns
if the bishop takes here that's
completely fine going to be looking you
can see the dominance of the center with
the pawn so that's kind of what Bobby I
was thinking if black decides to take
here on c3 first we see a pawn come down
here to d5 says yeah I got to disrupt
the center of the board I can't let you
just dominate everything right here a 3
and then the bishop comes back here to
e7 not the most common move that you
typically see here
Bishop takes on c3 is the most common
but we do have vision on actually played
a bishop back here to e7 in a match 2019
so not too long ago and crushed one of
the the top players in the world so
anytime you have a recent game with a
variation that doesn't see all that much
play and they have a decisive victory
that's something a lot of players will
look at and say okay maybe this Bishop
to e7 makes a lot of sense my guess is
that went into some of the preparation
the black had but that's exactly played
Bishop here to e7 and then e for
continuing the plan that Fabiano has to
control the center of the board with his
pawns black takes here on e4 would you
see the exchange with the pawns and you
can see Fabiano setup has the three
pawns in the center of the board does
have a little weakened King side but
once he castles on the King side at some
point if he wants to it's very similar
to a King's gambit accepted line where
the rook is here on f1 controls this
semi opened file and can have a pretty
strong attack against his opponents from
here with UCC five just trying to break
up the center of the board here d5 and
then the exchange on board here in
Fabiana is a pretty aggressive pawn on
d5 once you can get your pawn to your
opponent's fifth rank here and then you
have support from your own pawn that's
always a good setup here castle on the
King side and then Bishop to e2 couple
options here from Fabiano he's
definitely to be looking to get his not
involved here to f3 at some point and
his Bishop to e2 instead of Knight to f3
which i think is pretty common as well
decides to start with Bishop here to e2
rook here to e8 and that appear to f3
Bishop down to g4 pinning down the
knight to the bishop Kass on the King
sighs we talked about this once to get
King side safety also wants to make sure
that his rook has a pretty aggressive
line that he can start to attack on 9 to
d7
just holding down the fort for the night
here on f6 also just no other square
can't come here to c6 it's being
attacked by the pawn on d5 definitely a
nuisance that black has to deal with and
then d6 and this is a pretty interesting
move from
bayano were and move number 13s this is
definitely in his preparation one of the
moves that they look at so after a
tournament they do interviews with the
players and they ask him different
setups and this is one that they asked
him about because it's a pretty bold
strategy you have a good setup here you
you have central control with your pawns
this pawns protecting this pawn right
here that night here on c3 nice central
set up for Fabiano anytime you push it
forward no longer has pawn control this
pawn here on c5 is not doing anything
now you have to start to defend that
with your other pieces your queen here
you can eventually get your knight up
here to b5 and protect that you can get
your Bishop dark-squared bishop here to
f4 and protect that but to know I'm
protected by the pawns and it's pushing
a little further than you're used to
seeing but Fabiana definitely in his
preparation felt like this was the
opportunity to push forward did not want
his opponent bringing his Bishop here to
d6 and started wanting to attack his
opponent right away vision comes back
here to f8 definitely not the spot you
want your Bishop to go to but don't have
any other squares for it to go to h3
forcing the bishop to come back here to
h5 does not want to give the bishop up
right away especially in an open board
state bishops tend to do better and then
Knight up here to b5 now this is move 15
on the board and Fabiano said his team
prepared for this specific position so
if you ever hear players talk about
they're preparing for tournaments and in
specific openings and variations they
get extremely in depth
Fabiana said this very specific position
his team was prepared for and was trying
to get to now you're assuming you're
your opponent is going very specific
moves
you gotta assume that he's gonna play
that Vishy Anand Bishop back to e7 early
on now they have strategies depending on
wherever they go but to look at this
position say this is exact what we're
going for
it's pretty cool to see Fabiano have
that preparation than actually play it
out on the board this puts his opponent
in a pretty tough spot because he is
threatening the knight up here to c7 and
this is forking both the rooks right
here and so how does black really
Spahn and black spent 30 minutes on this
move so definitely not the easy position
trying to figure out the best way at the
end of day chose rook to X both Fabiano
and crew looked at this and said
afterwards probably not the best move a
couple options instead of rook to e6 one
would be Queen to b6 the other one would
be a rook here to b8 look in those both
real quick if Queen to b6 you know if
the knight came up here to c7 yes
attacking both of the rooks right here
but then the bishop takes after the
knight takes then the rook takes here
maybe Knight up here to h4 could see an
exchange on board black is gonna be in
you know a decent shape white definitely
came up with a rook advantage and black
gave up you know the rook in exchange
for a minor piece and a pawn
if instead of the Queen coming here to
be a to the other option that they
looked at would be for this rook to come
to be 8 because now if the knight came
to c7 then you could see the rook just
take here on e2 after the Queen takes
bishop takes here on d6 and then maybe
that comes back to to b5 here
Bishop comes down to g3 but then the
knight takes on a7 which doesn't have to
could stay on this b5 score but if it
does then all of a sudden black has a
pretty aggressive setup yes gave up some
material here but you can see both these
Knights the bishop all attacking on the
King side Queen can easily get involved
into the game so those are the options
that they looked at but on the board
state it played rook to e6 and it seemed
like he was just trying to stop Knight
to c7 which this absolutely does
because rook taking here on d6 it shuts
it all down this Knight can't take here
on a 8 because the Queen would fall here
on a d1 so it absolutely stops that not
necessarily the best movie that he had
in this position
Fabiano very quickly played Bishop to f4
said he was pleased to see rook to e6
was prepared for Queen coming here to b6
or rook here to b8 that's what his team
said because he was already preparing
for Bishop to f4 so since he's kind of
forced to do this he said that was in my
preparation as well
Asics forcing of the knight to move
knight comes up here to c7 attacking of
the rook rook comes down to e4 here
since this Knights attacking both of the
rooks decides to go and bring his bishop
back here has a great spot with his
knight right here now looking to do
anything doesn't want to give up his
bishop quite yet square here on h2 is a
fantastic square really wants to control
this pawn here on a d6 II feel like
that's the most critical square on the
board right here outpost 4 is Knight
right here both this Queen and his
bishop are eyeing down to defend that
square remember his pawn is not able to
protect it so as to make sure he uses
his other pieces black rightfully so
trying to attack that even if he has
some awkward exchanges once to get that
Bishop off the board now the work comes
over here to c8 since it was under
attack here pawn up here to g4 forcing
the bishop to do something either
retreat or exchange and black goes
all-in decides to take that material
after the pawn recaptures Knight takes
here on a g4 so all the pawns in front
of Fabiano's King side are gone but he's
also giving up some material right here
in exchange now this really not much
else black can do here doesn't have the
best setup so has to try to make
something happen but it's not clear how
he's gonna start getting all his pieces
involved into the game to start to
attack his opponent and actually win
this game Bishop to d3 attacking the
rook right here black decides let's go
and start gobbling out material Bishop
takes here on e4 very important of it
Fabiano captures correctly if he
captures with this knight right here
that would be a huge mistake because the
Queen can come down to g5 and then King
to h1 recover here to h4 same thing as
if he were to capture with his King King
takes on h2 now Bishop to d6
check awkward spot here Knight to f6
Bishop takes but now the Queen down here
to d7 check so you don't want to have
your King exposed right here the knight
on f3 definitely want to make sure that
it is stopping the Queen coming up here
to g5 so that's why I decided to go
ahead and take with his Bishop here on
e4 giving up his rook here on f1 so
that's that's completely okay with me
Queen so Queen swings over here and
recaptures on f1 now the bishop takes on
d6 and then the knight comes back here
to d5 so I have the outpost here on b5
for a while can't go back there because
the pawn on a6
d5 is just as good really controlling
the center of the board both sides equal
and material as far as point-wise one
minor piece is worth about three pawns
in material but you can really tell that
Fabiano has a lot more aggressive pieces
controlling the center of this queen and
rook it's gonna be very difficult for
them to attack with anything more than
themselves where Fabiano you can look at
it the bishops already attacking this
pawn right here can easily start to get
the other night involved into the game
this night here on d5 is much better
place than the knight back here on d7
can swing his rook over and get involved
into the action so I'm not saying it's
an overwhelming position for Fabiano but
but definitely has the upper hand just
as far as an active board stay then we
see g6 h3 just starting to attack on the
King side of the board
g7 King here to h1 so a couple things
with this one he wants to make sure that
he gets his King off the dark squares
when you get into the endgame you want
to look at the threats that your
opponent has and one of those threats is
this dark square bishop so there could
be some discover attacks if maybe the
bishop came down here to h2 just doesn't
want to have to worry about that so the
bishop no longer is a threat to this
King also the only other threat is if
the Queen comes down at some point to d5
which it can't one
because that's being protected by the
pawn here on c4 but now this entire
diagonal is pretty much safe for the
king you know could eventually come to
c6 but the first move they do would have
to come to is d5 influenced attack it
would have to have a couple moves before
it could come to c6 white could respond
in that fashion so h1 is a pretty safe
Square even though there's no ponds in
front of it now that it comes down to e5
attacking the knight Fabiano says I need
all my material this is extremely
valuable to me so he brings his knight
over here to h4 then the pond comes down
to h5 would be a mistake to play Knight
takes on c4 you can see the action
starting to go to the Kings side the
board if you've watched my videos before
it's all about having the material
involved into the game Knight coming
back to c4 yes it gets a pawn but that's
not what the game is about this would be
a huge mistake because after Knight to
f5 check no real good way for black to
continue if the pawn takes here this
eventually would lead to checkmate it's
a pretty extensive checkmate here but
after rook to g1 there's no real way for
black to hold on to this if instead he
doesn't take right away maybe King to h8
this is going to be bad as well we're
over here to f1 maybe the pawn takes
here but this is still going to be
completely fine for whites
he could take material here he can swing
his rook over but at the end of the day
he's probably taking with this bishop
right right now it's going to end well
for for Fabiano so as you can imagine
decides not to take this pawn that's not
what you should be doing
he plays h5 not necessarily the best
move either but it just doesn't have too
many options as far as getting his
material where he needs it to be rook
swings over here to g1 so everything we
wanted Fabiana to be doing as far as the
setup that's exactly what he's doing he
understands this position remember he
was preparing for that specific setup on
or on move number 15 that all leads to
just a few different in games that he
would expect to see this being one of
them so he he knows exactly how to get
his mitts here over to the kingside
start to attack his opponents now the
bishop comes back to f8 that's
definitely not doing anything productive
in all honesty but again there's not too
many great moves for black to go to
Knight to f4 putting a lot of pressure
on the square g6 here but the bishop the
two knights and the rook here all eyeing
down on that pawn on g6
Knight to g4 it's an outpost also
blocking some material right here the
rook attacking the pawn that's okay
Fabio says I have other plans here I'm
gonna go ahead and take your pawn here
on h5 after the pawn takes a bishop here
to f5 that's being protected by the
knight nh4 attacking both the knight and
the rook up here bishop comes to e7 just
moving back yeah it's not really doing
too much Bishop takes here on g4 after
the pawn takes Queen takes on g4 you can
see things are going down pretty quickly
for black here
Bishop to a g5 and then Queen up here to
h5 and there's just no way to stop all
the threats here eventually you could
see Knight to f5 check you could see the
rook come up here to g5 as well it's now
being protected by the Queen the bishop
can't really move because it's being
pinned down by the rook so oh no it's
just all bad and you can even see that
the Queen it would really like a
perpetual check the only way to do that
is if it were to come down in attack on
d5 which we talked about it's protected
by the pawn here on c4 so White's just
doing everything right in the game in
this but in this spot a black decided to
resign so congratulations to Fabiano on
getting the victory in game number 2 we
now have a four wait sighs wait
competitors for players tie at the top
with one and a half points which means
they have one victory and one draw
Fabiano at the top here tied with one
and a half points we have young
neppo we have NBL then we have how
weighing he won the first game against
England he drew today so those four
competitors are all tied at the top but
Fabiano you know drawing against MVL
which has expected first game very
strong opponent there and then coming
back and winning the game you pretty
much needed to win the lowest rated
player you have the white pieces you got
to come out and win he executed his plan
flawlessly it was really cool to see him
both execute and then watch him in the
interview analyzing the board talking
about how is execute exactly how he
planned it so really really cool to see
happy for him hopefully he can continue
going on and hopefully go on to win the
tournament thank you guys so much for
watching
round number 2 again nothing else going
on in the world so hopefully you guys
are tuning in here and we will be back
tomorrow for round number 3 of the
candidates tournament